your job is to build yourself up and
[ __ ]
everybody else around you and their
opinions because i think
she's also asking two separate things
you know um you're asking
here's here's one thing by the way when
you forgive somebody
you're not actually giving them anything
it's actually more for you
yeah when you forgive somebody and you
choose to empathize with somebody's
situation
it gives you understanding and it allows
you to let go
you're not actually doing it for them
you have to understand some this is i
mean i don't know if people agree or
disagree with this but when i forgive
somebody
i'm not doing it for you yeah i'm doing
it for me and forgiveness doesn't mean
you're completely allowed to come into
my life
exactly forgiveness is just i understand
that you made a mistake
and it's i i'm moving past that yeah
like when i say like i forgive somebody
who has done some [ __ ] up things in my
past
that's not in all access all access
passed back into my life
that doesn't mean i ever forget all the
stuff that you've done yeah it doesn't
mean that it's a representation of who
that person is now
it's a representation of where i want to
be and where i'm at now
so if i forgive this person who did some
[ __ ] up things i'm saying like listen
i don't want to hold the [ __ ] against
you because it weighs me down yeah it
doesn't mean that you have to let
i have to let that person back in yeah
forgiveness to me is like
releasing the thought yeah of so you can
live
so you so you don't hold on to the pain
you don't keep thinking about it you go
you know what
i'm moving on so this is a release but i
think a lot of people confuse
forgiveness with i'm going to let you
have my trust again
yeah those are two different things it's
very different because trust is things
that you have to nurture
and build over time you have to take
baby steps into it right
just because you forgive someone doesn't
mean that now
they have this like open arm come back
into my life
everything is the way that it's gonna be
you know or should be or whatever
that's not the same [ __ ] and we'll have
that conversation too where some people
will say
you know i'm pretty sure we've heard
people in our life say this they go i
thought you forgive me i thought we're
cool
no i forgave you doesn't mean we're cool
though yeah that means that
you know now i can be very cordial with
you so
i i don't want you to confuse that like
like joe said everything is a is a
process
right so if you do want to let your
parents back into your life and you know
people do have this phrase where they
say you know you only get one set of
parents a hundred percent true
but it doesn't really erase all the
stuff that they've done to you in the
past
i'm not telling you to hold on to these
things and i'm also not telling you at
the same time
is to just openly just let them back
into your lives you have to understand
where are you at right now yeah
if you're a strong enough individual
where you can go ahead and
talk to your father who is incarcerated
talk to your father who
who made a choice to leave you if you
have
the mental capacity if you have the
wherewithal to withstand that
then please by all means when you are
ready do it yeah
but it's going to take steps it's not
something that you're going to say
okay you know what i'm being a little i
feel like i'm being [ __ ] up to my dad
i'm just going to let him write it no
pump your [ __ ] brakes and then take
those steps
maybe send him a letter right start
there ask him questions get to know him
a little bit and even with your mom too
if you want to make that choice to have
that person in your life it's going to
be completely up to you
there is no set of [ __ ] rules if your
heart is not ready for that stuff if
you're in a stage of life right now like
you said where you're still a part of a
gang
and you're still trying to figure that
part out well well maybe we'll address
that later
right let's get to the forgiveness and
empathy part first
and then we'll we'll we'll pick up on
those parts because as of right now what
it sounds like
is that your life right now is is kind
of on very shaky stilts right like
you're
you don't really have your balance yeah
work on you find stability
and you're doing the best thing is you
realize that
you got to cut certain people away
that's the hard part i hate that
that that that saying people go oh blood
is thicker than water
[ __ ] that you need to be
like this is why i recommend everybody
to like if you can
move away for college find your own
person
move away from the city that you're in
because we become so dependent on the
opinions of
family and friends like and
the more people are in your ear or the
more you constantly worry about what
people think of you
you don't have the ability to form your
own thoughts and your own words
those are other people's words so what i
mean by that is like
we're constantly talking to ourselves in
our minds right like it's
constantly running and and most of it
could be like
worrying about what other people are
thinking or whatever that's why
you know sometimes these hippies go out
and they go i gotta find myself so i'm
gonna frolic in the [ __ ] indian
jungle
you know but they got a good point
because you need to
be in a completely new environment where
you're not doing the same routine yeah
and you're a different person and no one
knows who you are and if you can't
afford it or
or you can be in a just a different
place right and they see you differently
and
and you're treated differently like
you're gonna start thinking different
and i think that's super important to do
for everyone you have to have your own
thoughts
you have to be strong and you have to be
sure of yourself
before you go into these situations
because
the thing that a lot of people don't do
is like you know a lot of people might
watch their spending
but there's emotional spending and we
only have so much
on a daily basis right and a lot of
people are
just irresponsibly giving away their
like stress man that [ __ ] that shit's
dude
this is like some stuff that we've we've
been going through this year alone yeah
it's dealing with other people's stress
to the point where it starts to diminish
us on our everyday
yeah you know and i didn't realize this
stuff like i didn't get it either
because i'm trying to be the good friend
i'm trying to have an open ear and an
open heart and open mind
but there's a certain point where
they're there there's too much
take and not enough give you know and it
starts to wear us out mentally and
emotionally and it starts to affect my
personal life
so we have to be very mindful of this
stuff as well and there was a question
that you asked at the end too which was
very interesting you said am i being too
stubborn to let anyone
in due to my defense mechanisms or do i
have a right to feel
and a force the way that i feel i think
that's a
i think that's a very weird way to
question i don't think we're talking
about enforcing
negative habits right i don't think you
should enforce a negative habit but you
should understand why you do have a
defense mechanism for letting people
close to you yeah there's once you start
to understand that and it seems like in
your case therapy would be a very good
situation
if you don't have positive people in
your life right now that you could speak
to and give you
uh uh lend you an ear to listen to all
these problems uh therapy might be the
route for you
i i it's not for everybody it doesn't
work for everybody but it seems like for
me in my
in your case it sounds like therapy
would work yeah just because
um i i don't want you to feel like
having your
your walls up 24 7 to everybody is a
good habit to have
i think it's smart i think it's smart to
keep your [ __ ] close to your chest
but when you kind of stop when you kind
of let let your past define you
and your future relationships this is
where
uh like kind of problems will begin to
out just because like you don't know who
to trust anymore
you're not really practicing um
developing relationships now now every
time that you're with somebody you have
a red flag up
and you're expecting people to fail
around you which i have seen
consistently a